all right let's
let's jump right in then um
[Music]
quick recap so we basically just
reviewed prerequisites for the course
um the hope is um and all of you are now
more or less on the same page in terms
of prerequisites
um also the prereq the the kind of
material that we covered in the
prerequisites give you a flavor of
you know the kind of uh mathematical
background you're expected to have and
the kind of
you know problems that you'll be solving
in the homework so hopefully that's
that's informative for you
in terms of um expecting what to come
what comes in the rest of the course so
we covered linear algebra
uh and we we went over some matrix
calculus
uh matrix calculus uh mostly uh uh
we are we are interested in in you know
for example uh
taking derivatives of a scalar value
function with respect to a vector valued
input you know that's the most common
thing we'll be doing uh in this course
uh either vector value input or
matrix valued input but more most of the
times it's a scalar value
output which is going to be like your
loss function we're going to cover that
today
we also covered probability theory some
some
parts of probability theory
and then on friday we we touched upon
maximum likelihood expectation that's
you know just just
uh a small part of mathematical
statistics that's kind of
uh relevant to uh or that part that's
most relevant
to this course and um
we saw the example of how you can how
you can use maximum likelihood
estimation to
estimate the parameters of a gaussian a
multivariate gaussian
and we saw that um what what
the estimators that we obtained for the
mean and covariance
happen to be very intuitive ones right
for example the mean
the mean estimator turned out to be just
the average of the given you know
axis and the covariance happens to be
the sample covariance of of the
given inputs so it's it's nice to see
that
you know the intuitive definitions
happen to you know
be well grounded in some solid theory
so today we're going to switch gears and
start supervised learning
supervised learning is basically
deals with problems where we are trying
to learn a mapping
from some input x to some output y
right and the input x and y
are could be anything um most of the
times
we're going to be dealing with problems
that are either regression problems or
classification problems those are like
the most
common kind of machine learning problems
and depending on the problem for example
if it is regression
right and let us say we are trying to
predict
the price of say houses
and you are given the living area
and this is the price
okay so you may have
let us call this in in square feet
so let us say you are given a data set
that has mappings
x and y or pairs of x and y where x
is where each example denotes
ah one one house and the
x of that row is the is the
living area in in some unit and the y of
that row is the price
in some unit right and given this data
set
we could for example plot it like this
so the unit here square feet and the
unit here is thousand dollars
and you may get
right so ah
what we have here so here we have a plot
where
each dot represents one row right
and the x coordinate of the dot is the x
value and the y coordinate of the dot is
the corresponding y value
and this is just a scatter plot of the
housing prices data set and
the goal here is to learn some function
let's call it
a hypothesis
the reason it is called hypotheses is
not very crucial
so we want to learn a hypothesis we will
call it
h of x which is some function of x that
is similar to
or um that gives you an output
that is as close as possible to y
that is the that is the goal of a
regression problem
right and in there are some other cases
where
what you are trying to learn is a
classification problem
[Music]
where
right and here
x one and x two so here this was
x and this was y x of scalar value
but imagine a different problem where
your
x's have two have have two
attributes instead of just one attribute
let us say there was
a second attribute uh you could call it
you could call it
for example number of bedrooms
right and in and and there's going to be
a corresponding
ah maybe let me just
write this differently let us say you
have a different
data set where you have x one x two
and y and each example again is one row
and your y's are zeros and ones
and your x would be some values where
zero and one tell you what class the
example belongs to
and our goal is to learn some kind of a
classifier
which is you know some hyperplane that
divides your
exes into two parts and the the uh the
goal is to learn
a suitable hyperplane such that most of
the positive examples are on one side
and most of the negative examples are on
the other side
right these are two different kinds of
supervised learning problems
and we call it supervised because with
each example
there is a corresponding y that's given
to us which is like
that's the supervision signal where it
tells you what the right answer is
for each given example right and for the
probably the first third or first half
of the course we are going to be
focusing on
supervised learning problems and the two
most common problems we are going to be
looking at
are regression and classification
right and to set up the basic
terminology
we're going to stick with this
terminology in fact throughout the
course
in supervised settings we're going to
call the inputs as x
and the outputs as y
n is going to be the number of examples
in our training set
right we are given a training set from
which we want to learn some
hypotheses and the number of examples
in the training set is is going to be n
in all your homeworks
and and you know through the rest of the
course and we're going to call the
a given pair x y as an example in a
supervised learning training set
now d is going to be the number of
dimensions of our input
in this case d was 1 in this case d
is 2 right but d could be you know an
arbitrarily large number
of dimensions of the input and we're
going to use superscript
i with a parenthesis to indicate that it
is the
ith example so x i would be
the x1 you know
x1 x2 of the ith example and y
i will be the corresponding
y i will be the corresponding label so
we we generally call
the y's as labels
are ground truth
and x will be called your input so y
is the example output or you can call it
or ground truth
right and ah when given a pair x i y i
together they form the ith example right
super ah
supervised learning example any
questions about this terminology
so not to confuse whenever there is a
parenthesis you know it means we are not
taking the i
th power of x or the ith power of y it
means you know it's just the ith example
right and in the case of ah regression
problem y
i will be a real valued number
right and in case of classification
y i will be y i
will be in 0 or 1 if it's binary
classification
if it's a multi-class classification
then y i will be you know
it can take more number of discrete
values
right so this this is you know uh to set
up the uh terminology
uh any any questions about the
terminology
if not let's let's um
let's jump into supervised learning
right so the big picture of supervised
learning we saw this picture
uh is you're given a training set
training set is the set of x i
y i pairs where
i is from 1 to n right this means
a set of x i y i pairs n and
n of them and
using this training set we want to run
it through some learning algorithm
now the the specific algorithm that we
choose
will depend on what y i is for example
if it's real valued then it has to be
a regression learning algorithm if it's
discrete valued then it has to be
a classification algorithm and the
output of the learning algorithm
is our hypothesis or the learned
hypothesis
sorry this this h h of x is going to be
the output of the learning algorithm
and this this output or this model that
we call or the learnt model
let us call this the learnt model
can now take a new axis let us call this
x test right and output
the corresponding y hat
right so um this is the
the uh the big picture
of supervised learning and all the
algorithms that we are going to study
are going to follow this pattern right
so we start with the training set
we will run it through the learning
algorithm we obtain a model
and the model can now take examples from
what we call as the test set
or you know these could be examples that
that are fed into the model when you
actually deploy the model in production
and the the the goal here
is that even though we are learning from
a fixed set of examples
we hope to generalize well to examples
that we have not seen before
so x test in general will be an example
that your model has never seen before
and we hope to ah we hope that the
algorithm that we have learnt of the
model that we learnt will output
whys that are you know kind of correct
in some way
so with that ah let us start with our
very first
learning algorithm linear regression
so in linear regression x
is an r d and y
is an r right
and that is the training sector that we
are given
and n such things
in such examples
and now we want to learn ah a hypothesis
which belongs to a family what do we
mean by that
so in this in this setting
we didn't we did not impose any kind of
restriction on what
h can be it could be any function
whatsoever that takes x as an input and
produces some real
some some uh some y however
that is a very broad class of algorithms
a very broad class of hypotheses and we
want to limit the
the family of hypotheses over which we
are going to learn
in some way and the most
simplest form of such a hypothesis is
called a linear hypothesis
and we are going to write it in this way
h
theta of x is equal to
x naught plus
theta 1 x 1 plus
theta two x two plus
theta d x d
right ah what is happening here
so the hypothesis that we want to learn
has some parameter theta and
theta is in this case
well before i i tell what um theta is
this should be theta not
so the hypothesis that we learned
comes with a theta vector
that has d plus one components
right one through d corresponding to the
axis and and
ah another theta naught so theta naught
or theta is in
our d plus 1 this is the extra
plus 1 that we get and the goal
of linear regression is to learn
a suitable set of parameters theta
that that make a
y value as close as possible to h theta
of x
right that is the that is the that is
the goal of
of learning algorithm and this we can
also write h theta of x
is equal to summation of
i equals 1
to d
theta i x i
plus theta naught right
and we will adopt the convention that
we will add a new column to our axis
let us call it x naught and that will be
equal to 1 for all the examples
right and which means
i can we can now write h theta of
x to be theta naught
x naught plus theta 1 x 1 plus
theta d x d
and this is also is written i equals
this time from
0 to d theta i
x i and
this can also be written as theta
transpose x
right this this additional
term that we include in all our examples
where we just set it to one is also
called the intercept term
and this is mostly just for notational
convenience
right ah there is there is you know
there is absolutely no difference
between
this version and this version except for
notation here we have an annoying
extra additive term here there is no
annoying extra additive term that's
about you know it's just notational
difference
now
given this this this family of
hypotheses
that we want to limit ourselves to where
the specific member of the family is
decided by the specific theta vector
that is
that is used we are going to define
something called as a cost function
or it is also sometimes called the loss
function
right and in this cost function or loss
function we want to capture
the amount of displeasure
a specific hypothesis causes to us in
some way
right and a common a very commonly used
cost function
for regression problems is
called the squared error
and we're going to define it like this
so all the cost functions or loss
functions
in this course will be called j right
and we call it a cost function when we
want it to be
small we the the desired output for a
cost function should be
you know small and this is going to be
defined as
half of i
equals one two
right so what is happening here
we have n training examples i from 1 to
n and for each example
we take the hypothesis
that that we obtain by some given theta
that is an input to the cost function
calculate what that hypothesis
will uh what output that hypothesis
will output and calculate the squared
error between the correct answer
and the output of that hypothesis and
square it
right this is also called the squared
error
and this is a very commonly used loss
function
right and for different values of theta
the cost function
will evaluate to different
different values for the given training
set
yes question
why do we have a half here a good
question i'll come to that shortly
um the the
the thing to uh observe here is that
for the from the cost functions point of
view theta is the only variable
right the training set that we have
given is
is kind of embedded in this function it
is fixed right
and if you if you obtain a different
set of training a different training set
of having
different features and and and labels
the cost function is going to be
different
so the thing that makes one cost
function different from another
is one of course the functional form and
also
the training status itself so the
training set the training data that we
have
is kind of embedded into the cost
function right that's that's
that's something you want to keep in
mind
right and now the goal is to find
theta hat is
which somehow minimizes the cost
function right
theta and you know this is
theta of i equals one to n
h theta of x i
minus
y i square right so we want to
find that theta that minimizes the cost
function
to the smallest value possible
right any any questions so far yes
sure so the question is should we be
dividing it by the number of examples to
ah to normalize this so
if our goal is to find ah
the lowest possible cost itself or the
loss
value itself then yes
it matters a lot whether we normalize
this by n or not
but the goal here is to find the
argument which is you know
what is the value of theta that
minimizes this the most right
and the value that minimizes the value
of theta that minimizes the cost the
most
is the same whether you know the cost is
this value or the cost is this times one
over n
right it you can take one over n you
know outside and the value that theta
evaluates to will always be the same
so in terms of if the interest is in
finding the small theta then it does not
matter whether you
normalize it by n or not good question
right now the question is now how are we
going to perform this minimization
right what's what's what ah what do we
do to actually perform this minimization
because this is just a mathematical
expression this is not an algorithm
right the algorithm will tell us how we
are going to perform this minimization
process
right and this brings us to
our first algorithm what we call as
gradient descent
right so
to perform gradient descent ah let me
let me start with some pictures too
right what i have drawn here
are so the two axes are x one
through let us call this x d imagine
there are you know this is
you know in a d dimensional space uh
it's easy to visualize it in a
two-dimensional space but you know
it's it's it's representing a
d-dimensional space
and what i have drawn here is the
contoured plot of the cost function
right now this plot
is fundamentally different from the two
plots we saw over there
over there the axes were data and here
the axis is the parameters
right a very different plot right we
have the
the the axis
to be the parameters and this is the
contour plot of
of the cost function what's the contour
plot
yes
so good question good question so uh
the question is shouldn't the uh y-axis
be j of theta
and uh the theta one and and through
theta d b
be kind of uh on the x-axis um that
so um the answer is this is a contour
plot
right in a contour plot what we what we
do is
we trace out the set of all
the set of all points in in theta
which output a specific value of j theta
so this
corresponds to j of theta equals
1 and this corresponds to
j of theta equals 2 and this corresponds
to
j of theta equals 3
right it's it's a very different way of
of of looking at
at uh of of plotting things right
the the value of j theta is not visible
here
and it is it's kind of implicit in the
shape
of the contours that we draw right
now a few things that you can observe is
that
what can we say about the shape of j
theta here
yeah it's like a bowl shape where it is
minimized at this value
and as you as you kind of move farther
away in the parameter space from
this value your the cost function
evaluates to larger values
right is is this clear yes question
so the question is can we also not think
of this as a
dome shape right um you could th
this would also be the contour plot
offered of a dome shaped
uh function if the values
were in the other way this is three this
is two this is one
then uh for for these values of of j
theta then this would be a dome shape
right now as we get closer to the center
the value j theta evaluates to become
smaller and smaller so it kind of you
know
comes down to as as we move to the
center
good question
now the the cost function that we
described over here
where theta is in some d plus one
dimension because of the extra intercept
term
right so perhaps this is theta d plus
one
right now the goal is to find
the theta that minimizes this cost
function
so assume this cost function takes the
shape it could be you know
some shape and now we want to find
a theta that minimizes this cost
function
um to the smallest possible value
yes question
very good question so how do we know
that um
there is only one value of theta that
minimizes uh the cost function
uh in general it need not uh if you
uh the correct way to actually write
this is you know theta belongs
to argument where argument gives you a
set of minimizers
right there could be multiple values of
theta that minimize your
minimizer function for example imagine
this to be the cost function
and your cost function has this shape so
any theta along this line
is a minimizer it's not a bowl shape
it's just you know
that it's just that the minimum value
can be attained by multiple values of
theta along the line in
in such cases argument is actually a set
of theta values
but for for the most part we'll be
assuming that there is one unique
uh minimizer good question
so um so our our um
our goal is to find the value of of of
theta
where j theta is the smallest and for
this we're going to use an algorithm
called gradient descent
now how does gradient descent work so
gradient descent we start with a random
initial value of theta so
we set theta let's call this theta
naught
equal to you know some initialization
a common initialization is to just start
with
theta naught equal to z at the origin
right
theta naught now it's uh
again important not to confuse with the
superscript i'm using here
if it is data then the superscript means
the ith example
right now if you are running gradient
descent
the superscript over here indicates the
time step you know after what iteration
we are
uh you know the value of theta that we
get at a particular iteration
right so uh set theta naught uh you know
initialize it to some value it could be
the origin
and then
so first i'm going to write it in in in
the partial
partial derivative notation and then in
a gradient form
so theta
j of 1 will be equal to
theta j of 0
minus alpha times
which
what does that mean so we are at
theta naught ah equal to zero
or or a theta naught so first what we do
is we find the partial derivative
of the function j with respect to
some coordinate j right
j can take a value between one to d plus
one
right and we calculate the partial
derivative of the loss function with
respect to j
and maybe i will use a different color
over here we have multiplied by
some constant alpha
right where alpha is what we call as a
learning rate
and we repeat this for all j's
for all j
in 1 to
d plus 1 right
and this is with this rule
we calculate we we calculate
theta j for for the next
iteration right and that is going to
give us
for example
theta 1. now what's happening here
the an easy way to understand this
is to look at this with with the vector
notation
so in the vector notation this will look
like theta 1
is equal to theta naught
minus alpha times gradient
with respect to theta of
right in this notation which is
the same as this
notation
so we have the loss function j over here
and the gradient of a scalar
valued function with respect to theta
will give you the direction of steepest
ascent
right so if we are at this value
the gradient of j of theta with respect
to theta
will tell us that you need to move in
this direction
to improve theta to to increase the
value of j theta
right instead what we do is
we flip the sign make it a negative
which means now we are looking at this
direction
and update theta
by moving it by a small amount in the
direction of steepest
descent right so the step size that we
move
right this difference
is alpha times
negative gradient
right we started a theta naught
calculate the direction in which j theta
increases
the most flip the sign
and take a small step in that direction
where the step size
is decided by alpha
any questions here yes question
so theta 0 can it be random theta 0 is
some kind of an initialization
and a common initialization is to start
at 0.
you can actually initialize it to any
any value
and a topic that is a slightly more
advanced
is that if your cost function is convex
which is it is like a
bowl shaped function then the value that
you initialize it to does not matter you
always can you know
end up when this algorithm ends you
always reach the same value
nice question
good question how do we know we are not
trapped in a local minimum i'm going to
postpone that question for now and
assume you know we don't have local
minimums
we will deal with local minimums later
yes question
yes in practice what value of alpha
should we take
great question and there is no um
it it so happens that
well-defined cost functions like you
know gradient descent on
say the linear regression are tolerant
to a whole range of alphas
and al uh you know um but in practice
you actually experiment with a few
different values of alphas
and and figure out which one works best
for you
right so this is one step
you know uh this is a one step in
partial derivative notation this is one
step in vector notation
right and i personally feel the vector
notation is easier to kind of understand
this looks a little cryptic
whereas over here there is a very clear
geometric meaning where
you are at one particular value you know
in this in this
parameter space you you calculate the
gradient of the cost function with
respect to you know the current position
um and that gives you the direction of
ascent
you flip the sign take a small step in
that direction and
you you reach a new theta theta one
such that j of theta one
is
hopefully
less than j of theta naught why do i
write hopefully here
because if you take two larger step
you can overshoot and reach you know
reach a point that is
actually at a higher cost so uh tuning
the learning rate is important because
you don't want to overstep
right and as long as your learning rate
is is well tuned
for your cost function then this
hopefully will be true most of the time
right and what we do we iterate this
so repeat
till convergence
now we say repeat till convergence what
does that mean
what we mean is if if we if i write this
as
theta of t plus 1
equals theta of t minus
alpha theta
t if we repeat this process
we will get
a series of parameters right
theta zero theta one
theta two
theta t theta
t plus one
right we get a series of values
now for those of you who are who have a
more advanced math background and know
what convergence means
then we are talking about the
convergence of this series
right when the series converges you can
stop
iterating now however in practice
defining the convergence has a more
practical definition so there are many
ways to check for convergence
one way to check for convergence is to
look at the norm
of theta p minus
theta t minus one
right has have you stopped after taking
a step
um have you reached a stage where theta
t to
uh theta t minus one was you know what
was was too small or ignorably small
that's one way to check for convergence
another way to check for convergence is
has your loss stopped going down so j of
theta of t minus
j of theta of t minus one
i am putting it as a norm but this is
just a scalar
right that's another way to check for
convergence yet another way to check for
convergence is
was the norm of your gradient too small
right so you can look for the norm of
the gradient and and check if the norm
of the gradient became too small
or you can you can you can look at the
difference between the two
you know the the previous uh uh
parameter and the current parameter and
check if you know that
that difference uh got smaller than some
epsilon
or if you know your the the cost value
itself if it stopped
um stopped reducing right there
there's no right answer for how you want
to check for convergence in practice
these are just
you know a few few thoughts on how you
can uh implement
so in your in your code there would be
some kind of an epsilon that you define
which is you know maybe 10 to the minus
5 or you know
some such small number and you keep
iterating this in a loop by you know
where you know think of t as your
iteration number and you keep iterating
until one of these values becomes
smaller than epsilon so that would be
like your breaking condition for the
loop
yes question
oh no this just notation so you know
think of it as the absolute value
right so if it stops
so the question if i understood right is
can we not have
um a way to intelligently set
alpha for each iteration to get closer
you can you can do a whole lot of you
know such variants and
there are a lot of variants of this
algorithms that exist in practice
but for the most part we kind of exploit
the fact that
as you get closer to to the minimum
the gradient also keeps becoming smaller
right so as as you get closer the
overall update even for a constant alpha
the overall update also keeps becoming
smaller because your gradient also
becomes
smaller and smaller i mean the the uh
intuition there is that
once you reach the absolute minimum
right
so supposing this is j of theta right
once you reach the absolute minimum the
gradient is zero
right so and the gradient keeps getting
smaller and smaller
as you you know approach approach the
minimum right so
uh most of the times some kind of a
well-tuned value for alpha constant
value
is is you know works works well you know
good question
any other question right
so what is what is happening now we
we saw this this algorithm called
gradient descent
where we are given some kind of a cost
function which we visualize
with contour plots that is defined over
the parameter space
right and the shape of the cost function
has the data set kind of embedded in it
right if you chose a different
training set then maybe your cost
function is tilted differently or has a
minimum
at a different location but the training
set is kind of embedded inside
this cost function itself and now we
start with a random initialization of
theta and we keep
taking small steps in the direction of
the negative gradient
and we keep taking steps until we hit
some kind of a convergence
convergence condition and there are many
choices for
defining what the convergence condition
is and we take this algorithm
which we call as gradient descent and
apply it
to the linear regression cost function
right we take this algorithm and we
apply to
the linear regression cost function what
does that mean
it means the update rule that we have
the update rule that we have over here
will take a specific form
so the methodology that we are following
here is
is common for pretty much all the
algorithms that we are going to be that
we are going to be
studying where we define
given the training set we define some
kind of a cost function
defined over a parameter space and use
gradient descent
to find a parameter that minimizes that
cost function
right this this is a common template
that we repeat over and over
for different algorithms the algorith
for our different models the model will
give us
different cost functions right and the
corresponding cost function
will be plugged into this algorithm
until we minimize it right that is going
to be a repeating pattern
throughout this class so in case of
you know gradient descent
on linear regression
right so gradient descent on linear
regression will look like this
repeat
until convergence
so first let's set theta naught equal to
some initialization
right repeat until convergence
theta t plus 1
equals theta t
minus alpha that's the step size or the
learning rate
times the gradient of respect to jeter
right now this is um standard gradient
descent and we when we apply to linear
regression
we replace the cost function with the
cost function of
linear regression so this is theta of t
minus half
respect to theta
and what's the cost function
y equals 1 to n
h theta of x i
minus y i
square let's simplify this further
theta of t minus alpha times
f gradient
half of
n h theta of x is
theta transpose x
theta transpose x i
minus y i
square right so just to make it clear
ah the thing that we are
minimizing with respect to is respect to
theta
and this is the only place where
theta appears right
the x's and y's are all given they are
just constants for the purposes of
optimizing this cost function which is
why we we
we think of the the training set kind of
being embedded
in in your cost function right they are
just different constants
as far as the cost function is concerned
right and let's let's um expand this
further
using our matrix calculus tricks
this is theta t minus
alpha of
one to n is the square um
this will give us two times i am sorry
ok so two times theta transpose
x i minus y i
times the
x i right
and now the two and the half cancel so
somebody asked why do we have
have a half in the in the in the cost
function the reason is only to just
make the gradient update rule look
simple
just just just the way multiplying it by
1 over n did not matter
in fact the the you know half also does
not matter except to make our
gradient expression look look simple and
this is
transpose to
alpha times
somewhat i equals one to n of
theta transpose x minus
x i minus y i
times x i
right notice here that theta transpose
x is a scalar y is a scalar
so theta transpose x i minus y i is also
a scalar
so it is a scalar times
a vector and the dimension of this is d
right so it is you're summing over
a d dimensional vector scaled by some
scalar
and n such terms so this whole
expression
is d dimensional vector
right and theta t was also a d
dimensional vector
so we the the next theta t plus one
is a d dimensional vector minus some
scalar times a d dimensional vector so
this is also a d dimensional vector
right so when you when when you write
out
matrix calculus it's always always a
good good idea to make sure that the
dimensions match
any questions about any questions about
this
so this is the gradient update uh
algorithm where you repeat this over and
over
until one of the convergence conditions
hit
um with with your training set embedded
here
and once you once you um once this
algorithm converges
you would have solved linear regression
yes there was a question
yes so the question is what's the dim
what's what's t what are we talking
about uh theta over here
theta is uh the the set of all
all parameters which is vector valued
and the superscript over here
is basically saying you know which
iteration in gradient descent
are we at right so this is a d
dimensional vector
x is a d dimensional vector or maybe d
plus 1 to account for the
intercept so this is also d plus 1
dimensional and
h theta of x scalar y scalar and so on
any questions yes
if you take the log of the sum of the
square errors
uh i'm sorry i missed the question
what's what's
not really so taking a log wouldn't
wouldn't uh
so the reason though the one half exists
here is only to make this update rule
look simple
there's no other uh no other reason
because you know whatever constant you
have
uh you know half or or any other
constant you can always kind of counter
it by choosing a different alpha
right so this
no purpose for that all right so that's
gradient descent
however in practice
what we use is a variant of um so for
a lot of convex functions like this for
for example for linear regression
the algorithm that you know gradient
descent works perfectly fine
however there is a variant of gradient
descent called stochastic gradient
called sgd
so the way std ah works is
it is
so what let let us look at this gradient
uh descent
algorithm on linear regression here
so this is the update rule uh what we
have over here and we
repeat this over and over for each each
for each update so in order to
make so much of progress
so the goal is we start from here and we
want to reach here and these are small
steps of progress that you are making
each step that we are you know of
gradient descent is like a small
amount of progress that we are making so
in order to make so much of progress one
step worth of progress we need to
compute this step
right and for those of you who are who
are probably
kind of algorithmically minded you might
be wondering
for each small step of progress that we
want to make
we need to iterate over our entire
training set
right and the number of examples in your
training set could be a million it could
be a billion
right in order to to make a small
uh in order to make a small step of
progress we need to scan through our
entire training set with this algorithm
right and that can be extremely
expensive
if you're if your training set is too
big or if you're
uh if your model is also too big to
compute gradients on on so many examples
right and this motivates the the
sgd or the stochastic gradient descent
algorithm which is a variant of gradient
descent
where what we do is
we say theta of t
plus one is equal to
theta of t plus
rather minus
alpha times i am going to call this
j tilde of theta
where j tilde of theta
is in case of linear regression it is
going to be
half off
so what do we do instead of calculating
the gradient
of the loss function on the full
training set we instead
sample just one example
uniformly at random right and pretend
that is our entire training set pretend
that our training set has only one
example
calculate the gradient of
that cost function which has only one
random example
right and take a step in the direction
according to that
cost function and
we take one step and repeat this process
by sampling a new training example to
construct this
temporary or proxy loss function
specific to that example there is no
summation here
we use some example k and that k is
sampled uniformly at random
from your training set and for each
iteration
we sample a different example
right this might look this might look ah
it might be surprising you might wonder
would this even work
right the the intuition over here
is that
you know um
this is our ah j theta
theta one to theta d
and we start at some random position
in case of gradient descent
in case of gradient descent the
the trajectory followed by this sequence
of thetas
would look something like this
right you that we we are making
making ah we are making progress
in the direction of the final minima
and taking smaller and smaller steps as
we go closer and closer
right this would this is a trajectory
that gradient descent
would have taken whereas with
stochastic gradient descent
the the updates might look like this
right we start with it or not
right instead of calculating the
gradient
with respect to the true cost function
we are calculating the gradient with
respect to this proxy cost function
which has only one random example in it
right and we are going to make a step in
the negative
gradient of that you know proxy cost
function
and that is going to be your theta 1 and
theta 2 will be with respect to the next
random
example and what we notice is that
in while in the case of gradient descent
the direction was consistent
and always headed toward the local
minima
in stochastic gradient descent the
directions are a little
crooked so to speak right and you might
even encounter cases where you are kind
of
actually going in the opposite direction
of you know where you actually want to
go eventually
right but it so happens that by
following this algorithm
eventually you will reach
a region around the
true minima right and all
further updates of of a stochastic
gradient descent
is going to keep you confined to a small
ball
around the true global minima and the
radius of that ball
is going to be a function of the step
size alpha
right there's a lot of theory that that
um
that kind of precisely characterizes
this
uh so for example if you you know if
you're interested to go deeper into this
theory you can
um you can you can study stochastic
approximation
that give you that that formerly um
that precisely formulates the con the
behavior of sgd
but for from this course point of view
all we need to
know is that sgd works okay
so um sgd is it makes very noisy updates
because we're not taking the full set of
training uh the full training set at
every step
it's going to make noisy steps but on
average you're going to reach the global
minimum
or you're going to reach a region that
is you know sufficiently close to the
global minimum
and that region is characterized by the
um
by the step size alpha that you choose
yes question
so is there can you take a running
sample of uh
a running sum off of the previous
gradients
and and do some kind of an averaging of
them um
to kind of have less noisy updates
yeah there are lots of variants of of of
of gradients and and the um
the technique that you described is also
commonly called as momentum
so when you when you when you are when
you look up
all the different optimization
algorithms that exist for machine
learning
you know some of them are going to have
this parameter called momentum and that
does
something exactly what you described
where it keeps like a running average of
previous
descents to kind of make the updates
less noisy
so ah for true sgd
ah each time you pick an example you
randomly pick it
the next time you may pick the same
example but you don't care you know just
just pick it randomly
right but in a lot of uh actual
applications
uh and also in the notes what we see is
you kind of scan your training set from
top to bottom
preferably you want to shuffle your
trainings at once and
and just loop over your training set
from you know one through n
by doing a scan by using a different
example each time
and then you can just repeat again or
you know at the end of one sweep
you know shuffle it reshuffle it and you
know repeat again
no there is there is no restriction on
the minimum size of uh training
training set the algorithm works for any
training set
but if your training set is not too
large
then you know this regular gradient
reset might work well for you
also another thing to note is that with
stochastic gradient descent
you may need a lot more number of steps
to converge as compared to gradient
descent
but the cost of taking each step or the
computational cost of
each step is so small that it's well
worth
well worth it to have more number of
steps uh
but they are you know so much more
inexpensive compared to a full gradient
yes question
yeah so the question is uh can can we
can we do something in between gradient
descent and
stochastic gradient descent where
instead of one example we
we take a small batch of examples uh
and the j tilde theta is then defined as
a summation over that batch
of examples yes you can absolutely do
that and that's uh
that's called mini batch gradient
descent and in fact most
of um you know deep learning and neural
networks do exactly that where you take
a batch of examples uh where the batch
sizes is
some small number like 64 or something
yeah
is it more advantageous to use that
thing it could be more advantageous
um for for um
it so happens that the
the situations where we try where we
need to use
um sgd or mini batch sgd
happen to be with deep learning or
neural networks
where the cost function is not convex
right and once you have
a non-convex cost function it's very
hard to
it's very hard to analyze and make
precise statements of what helps and
what doesn't help
and so in in those situations it the
answer is almost always try and see if
it works better
right so that is sgd and gradient
descent
any any questions before we move on
so
now that we have seen sgd and gradient
descent
two different iterative algorithms they
are also called
numerical algorithms because um
in order to compute the values you
actually need a computer where you
where you code this algorithm and run it
and get a solution you don't have like
a mathematical expression for what the
final answer is right
you just describe this algorithm
implement it as code
execute it on a computer and it's going
to return some numerical values for your
theta
right and this is this is going to be
the
case for most of our algorithms where
we do not have a precise mathematical
expression for the final answer you are
going to define a numerical
solution an iterative solution and
you then need to code it up and find
a numerical answer for that particular
problem
yes question
yes that's what we are coming to know so
the only exception or
one of the few exception is linear
regression where there is
a closed form a closed form solution for
for minimizing the cost function over
here
now the reason why we first started with
gradient descent for linear regression
is because taking gradients is very easy
and it's easy to kind of
show you how gradient descent works
right but in practice
as an exception you know for linear
regression there's actually
uh a closed form solution which you can
use and
that's something we will see now
right so first let us redefine j theta
so first we saw j
theta to be we defined it as half
i equals one to n
right this was our cost function
now
let us first
rewrite this as in in in
a vectorized notation
let us define the
what you call as the design matrix
x which is an n by d
vector right
and each
each row in this matrix is one input
input x vector right and we also define
y
y 1 through y n
right and now
theta to be vector theta 1
through theta d
or d plus 1. so
the row of each the row of each design
matrix is
d plus 1 dimensional if you include the
intercept term
and the vector theta is is a d plus 1
dimensional vector and y is
n-dimensional one for each
one for each example right now
the expression x
theta minus y
will be the matrix x multiplied by
the vector theta minus the vector y
right so x is in r
n by d theta is in
r or n d plus 1 theta is an r d plus 1
and y is an r n
right so ah multiplying ah
a matrix of n by d plus 1 times a vector
of d plus 1 will give us a vector in
our n minus
r n right and this will be just in r
n right so what does this look like
x theta is equal to
x 1 transpose theta
x i transpose theta
x n transpose theta
right minus y so we can include y right
here
minus y one minus
y i minus y n
and this is x theta minus y is this term
is this clear any questions on this
and we define the
j of theta to be half
x theta minus y transpose
x theta minus y
why is this so this is x theta minus y
we transpose it and you know take the
dot product this with this
so it's basically you're squaring each
term and summing them up
right does that make sense you are
squaring each term and summing it up
and you are dividing it by a half which
makes this
actually exactly equal to half
i equals 1 to n theta transpose
x i minus y i
square right so this is the same as the
original cost function that we have any
questions here
exactly the same here we are using
vector notation here we were just
you know iterating and having a loop
over every example this is just a vector
notation
right and now um
let's try to solve for theta from the
expression
equal to 0 right we want to we want to
set the gradient of this with respect to
theta to be equal to 0
and solve for theta from this from this
expression
right
so half
x theta minus y transpose
x theta minus
y now the reason why there is no
transpose between these two is because
this is not
one example it is the full matrix the
design matrix
right and in the matrix every example is
already in the form of a row vector
right so every example is already in the
form of a row vector it's kind of
pre-transposed for you
so this is this is a vector of
n dimension of scalars of n dimension
and this is equal to just the cost
function and now let's let's
um let's check through this
this is gradient of theta of half
i'm just going to expand this so x theta
transpose x theta
minus x theta
transpose y minus
y transpose x theta
plus y transpose y
right this is
respect to theta
half of theta transpose
x transpose x theta
minus
theta transpose
x transpose y
and these two are scalars and
these two evaluate to the same thing and
so i'm just going to make it 2
plus y transpose y
right any questions on how we went from
here to here
there was a question on piazza of how of
a similar
similar uh uh step we did for the
gaussian
mle of the mean of the gaussian this is
a scalar
x is a x is a a matrix theta is a vector
x theta is a vector vector dot vector is
a scalar
this is a scalar so
and if you have scalars the transpose of
the scalar is the same thing so
if you transpose this you get 2 times
the first expression so this is just 2
times
2 times that and
and now um let's observe a few things so
this is a vector
and this is some scalar this is some
vector and vector
our transpose another vector is a scalar
this is the by uh the quadratic form
that we've seen in the past right and
when we take the ah when we take the
gradients
we get half of
2 x transpose
x theta minus
2 x transpose y
and this is just 0 so this is going to
just cancel out
right and this this is the gradient and
we want this to be equal to 0
which gives us x transpose x
theta equals x transpose y
right and this equation that we have
here
is called the normal equation
and from this you can solve for theta to
be equal to
x transpose x inverse
x transpose y as long as x transpose x
is invertible
right and for now
let us assume x transpose x is
invertible
if you have two rows uh two columns in
your matrix that are duplicates of each
other then x transpose x
may not be invertible but we'll address
you know those kind of
oddities later for now assume x
transpose x is invertible
and this gives you an estimator
for theta hat
right so this is called the ah normal
equation
and it is it is it is only in the case
of
so linear regression is one of the few
cases where you can come up with an
exact solution
and and not limited to a numerical
solution
for which we need a computer right this
is an exact solution
for calculating theta hat or to
minimize a cost function because j
of this theta hat is going to minimize
your is going to minimize this to be the
smallest
right any questions yes
right so what's the use of the other
approach the the other approach
is uh we we use linear regression to
describe gradient descent because it is
easy to derive the update rules for for
the purposes of
you know education right you're going to
use gradient descent based approaches
for pretty much all other machine
learning algorithms like
that we're going to come across in this
course linear regression
is one exception which you can solve
with gradient descent there's no problem
solving it with gradient descent but you
also have a closed form
solution for linear regression which the
other algorithms don't have
any other question
now lets lets kind of
see a few more interpretations of this
right
there are ah
so there is a probabilistic
interpretation of this
right so in the probabilistic
interpretation
we make this assumption that the way our
y eyes are generated in our training set
is through this process so y i
is equal to theta transpose
x i plus
epsilon i where epsilon i
is some kind of a
gaussian noise with mean 0
variance sigma square
right so what does this mean it means
the way our data set is generated is
we start with some x for example if you
are talking about the
the price of a house the excess will
describe the features of that house
like the area or number of bedrooms
etcetera
right and there exists some unknown
theta vector that you know that we are
interested in calculating
and the way the corresponding y is
generated is by
taking the dot product of theta and
theta and
the features of the of of the input and
adding
a random gaussian noise
right now the noise that gets added to
each example
is a different noise but the noises are
distributed
according to a gaussian variable
according to a gaussian distribution
right does this one this this is the
assumption that we are making
right this may or may not hold true in
reality
but this we start with the way our our
we start with this assumption to
describe the way our data is generated
now then what we what we ah
what we then do is
swap the terms around so epsilon i
is is ah is a random gaussian
variable which means
epsilon i is also equal to
y i minus theta transpose x i
right just move epsilon over and
theta transpose x to the other side
and this term is therefore
right so y minus theta transpose x i
is also
distributed according to a gaussian
variable which now means that
right this is ah
this is the claim that we made because
epsilon i
is normally distributed
right y minus theta transpose x i is
also normally distributed
with with mean 0 and
variance sigma square which means
probability of y given
x has this density function
is this clear any questions of how we
went from here to here
yes
yeah so in this case ah the parameters
of this probability density of this
probability density is theta
right theta is the is the um
probability density that's given to us
or the parameter that's given to us
unlike the usual gaussians where the
parameter is is mu
this is a reparameterized version where
the parameters are theta
so what this means is
why i so ah that that's a good question
let me let me clarify this
a little further right so
gaussian variables have this this
property where so if y i minus theta
transpose x i
is is distributed according to ah
gaussian
now y i
minus theta transpose
x i is distributed as
normal right
this also implies
y i
because gaussians have this have this um
what's also called as location scale
property
where you can you can move your gaussian
if you add some constant
to your gaussian random variable then it
just
you know moves the gaussian there so
over here
nothing in this is random it's just some
constant
right so if y i minus theta transpose x
i is distribute according to this then
it means
y i is distributed according to a normal
distribution
that has mean theta transpose x i and
variance sigma square
right and now this is the mean and this
is the variance
and you know that's what you see
exactly so we are we are we are assuming
that
y i has is is distributed as a normal
random variable
as a standard normal variable whose mean
is different for different examples so
for for y 2
the mean is going to be theta transpose
x 2 right for y 1 is
the mean is theta transpose x 1. and
this statement is exactly same as this
statement
right so to to jump from here to here
so ah it's easy to kind of
go through these steps so if epsilon i
is y minus theta transpose x i
um distributor continue according to
gaussian that means
um you know y i minus theta is perfect
size is distribution according to a mean
zero gaussian
which also means y i this distribution
is distributed according to a normal
with mean theta transpose x i
and uh variance sigma square and
this can be you know and therefore the
probability density of y i
is given by this right so y i is the
is is the variable this is the mean
this is the variance yes question
yes i missed the one half thank you
thank you
is this clear right now
once we have this once we have uh
y i in this form we are now going to do
maximum likelihood
question
exactly so here we are given
the data x's and y's
which is distributed according to some
unknown parameter
and now the data is given and the
parameters are unknown
and we are going to do maximum
likelihood to
estimate the parameters
right so the data
is the x's and y's parameters
are generally it is mu and sigma square
but in this case the parameters are
theta
and sigma square but theta is not the
is not the mean right theta transpose
x is the mean for each y right so the
this is a a a conditional distribution
right and so we can write the
likelihood function as
i equals 1 to n probability of
y i given x i
with with the given theta right and we
are making an iid assumption that is the
case all the time
we assume that the epsilons the
epsilons over here are iid
which means we can break down the
likelihood as a product of n different
different terms
how are we doing with respect to n right
we have 10 moments with respect to
n and and then what we do is
instead of of the likelihood we take the
log likelihood right
and this is going to give us log
um log of that pdf
so the sum i equals 1 1 to
n i'm going to call this l theta
over square root of 2 pi
sigma square
x of
minus half
y i minus theta transpose
i squared over
sigma square
right let me write this a little more
clearly this is just
l theta equals
all right now lets
take a step back and kind of analyze
this
the function over which
the the variable over which we had
theta that comes up
here right and now
ah
with this likelihood function you can
kind of
you know zoom out and look at this
expression
and you can see that log and x bar
something that cancel out
right the the
2 pi sigma square is just some constant
we are assuming sigma square is some
just some unknown constant this is some
constant again
we have a minus half square so all this
is going to you know the the the
i guess the summary here is that you
know
by looking at this expression your
attention should naturally just
focus on this part right
everything else just just just just you
know goes away
right the
you can write this as sum over i equals
1 to n
log of some constant is some k
you don't care log and the exponent
cancel out
minus half some
sigma square right
y i minus theta transpose
x i square
there is a half right and so
is equal to i'm going to take this k out
or some n times k or some constant
minus 1 over
sigma square half
equals one to n
right so the likelihood function
the log likelihood function by making
a probabilistic assumption about the
noise
is going to give us the negative of
a scaled version of the original cost
function
right which means by performing maximum
likelihood
we are minimizing the squared error
does that make sense so this this this
is kind of
um whenever you see a gaussian
come into picture you know this is
probably the most important thing it is
the exponent of some
squared entity and when you take the log
likelihood you know the log and the
exponent cancel out
and you're going to be left with just
the the square term
right and it's going to come with a
negative sign
and because we are doing maximum
likelihood we are trying to maximize the
negative
of something which means we are trying
to minimize this
yes question
exactly what we have shown here is that
is that linear regression can be viewed
as performing maximum likelihood
where the noise that comes into each
example is assumed to be a gaussian
noise
right if you make the assumption that
the the x's and y's
have a linear relationship and have an
additive gaussian noise
then the maximum likelihood theory tells
you
what you need to do is exactly the same
as
minimizing the you know squared error or
ordinary least least squares
the the two are the two
approaches of you know defining the cost
function and minimizing it or giving it
a probabilistic setting and maximizing
the likelihood are exactly the same
right so to you know just me my
arg max of l theta
was equal to arc
min of
j theta right there are some extra
scaled versions but
we are not interested in the values but
we are interested in the arg max and the
argument right and they are exactly the
same
this question
yeah so the question is if we made uh uh
assumption that
uh epsilon instead of gaussian was
poisson what what would happen
and for that i would say wait till
[Music]
we're going to cover glms right yes
that's a very good question
and what we're going to see is is the
maximum likelihood
interpretation is actually more general
and you can you can
you can do many more things yes question
so the epsilon over here is actually the
difference between
kind of the true y value and the
observed y value like
theta transpose x i is like in a way
like the true price of the house
but what you observe has some noise in
it you know maybe the mood of the buyer
was
was bad that day or there's is some
noise that gets
added into the process and you are
making an assumption that the noise is
is gaussian
now in the last few minutes that
that we have ah i want to provide yet
another interpretation of linear
regression
right so we saw linear regression can be
solved through gradient descent or
through the normal equations we saw that
linear regression is
is actually the same as maximum
likelihood if you assume that
the noise is gaussian now
here is yet another view of linear
regression right
now if if ah
what we want to solve is x theta
equals y right now here x is
a matrix theta is a vector
and y is another vector right now
remember the the um the functional view
of matrices that we spoke about earlier
so you can imagine
an input space
theta 1 theta 2
theta d you have a matrix x
and you have an output space
y one y two y
n now let me intentionally keep this two
dimensional
so we have theta one two through theta d
right what this means is we have some
theta some some
parameter space theta
that's the input space to the matrix x x
is the design matrix
right now the rows of your the data is
actually in
x not in theta right and y
is is is the corresponding y labels
now what we want is to find theta
that that makes our output as close to
y as possible right we also saw in
when we were reviewing linear algebra
that
if x is not full rank then there exists
a subspace in x
a lower dimensional subspace that has a
one to one mapping between the input and
the output space right
now for now let's assume x
is full rank which means if x
is in is in d by n and d is the smaller
dimension then assume that
x has rank d right
and y is in an n dimensional space
so n is generally much larger right n is
much larger
and the given day so the training set
that we are given
is represented by this matrix x and
some point in this
output space of ys where this point
remember y's are all scalars so each
dimension
is representing a different example
right it's an n dimensional space
where each dimension represents a
different example
and there's going to be some subspace
in in the output space
that passes through the origin
which for which there is a bijection
between theta
and the subspace and also
the set of all points in the output
space that can be reached by theta
is limited to that subspace right we
remember that
now we
also spoke about projections right
now if you have a matrix x
whose columns define a set of bases
onto which we want to project something
right the projection matrix was anybody
remembers
x transpose x transpose
what x inverse
x transpose this was the projection
matrix so
this subspace defines the set of all
points that can be reached
through linear combinations of x right
and
those columns are you know basically the
columns over here
right and the projection matrix of this
output subspace
is this right
now which means the given y
supposing we are given some value y most
likely it's not going to reside in the
subspace it's because you know the the
the space the n dimensional space is so
much larger
and the d dimensional space d is so much
smaller than n
that very likely the y that we observe
is not going to lie
in the space exactly in the subspace
exactly right
and what we want to do is now
project this point onto the subspace
such that it is perpendicular right so
this
is our observed vector of ys
that we want to project on to the
subspace that that is reachable through
x
right and the the projection matrix is
going to be this
and what the the the point
on to which it gets projected
will have a one to one mapping with some
point over here
right so which means
x theta hat is going to be equal to
x x transpose x
inverse
x transpose y right does the projection
matrix
this is the vector that we want to
project right
and this basically kind of is another
way of seeing that you know
theta hat equals x transpose x inverse
equals 6 transpose y
right does it make sense so
this is the projection matrix that will
take any vector in the output space and
project it on to the column space of
of x and we take the vector y
and project it onto the column space of
x
and once it's in the column space of x
there will exist some
made some some some vector in the input
space that
you know because there's a bijection
between the the
the column space and the row space which
means
x theta hat equals
some some value will have an inverse
because there's a one to one bijection
that exists
and that inverse is is you know because
because
now you know x is now kind of invertible
because it's in that
space where the bijection exists theta
hat is is equal to x transpose x equals
x
x transpose x inverse x transpose y
right so
basically what linear regression is
doing is projecting
the y values onto the subspace reachable
through x
and then solving um finding theta hat
you know corresponding to that
projection
yes question i'm sorry
so how how do we know it's the optimal
theta uh
here optimal in the sense um
so so we we when when we spoke about
uh projections we discussed this
interpretation
that the point to which you get
projected is in a way
the closest possible point to the true
vector
right so in that way you're trying to
find a theta that will
that will take you to a point that is
closest to y
right and basically pythagoras theorem
tells you that the square of this
instance is equal to the sum of the
squares of
you know the each components and that
you know
turns out to be exactly equal so
pythagoras theorem tells you that
this is equal to the square of this
residual right
all right with that we will we will
conclude our
our survey of linear regression and
next we're going to start with
classification